- Hey guys, it's Justine
and today I am so excited.
Because we have got four different drones
that we're gonna be testing out.
The new Mavic Air just came
out so we're gonna test that
in comparison to the Mavic Pro Platinum,
the DJI Spark and the
Phantom 4 Pro Advanced.
And here's our little Mavic Air.
My precious.
I've never even seen that movie,
so I don't even get the reference.
So right now I'm updating one of the apps
before we go and then
we're gonna start flying.
♪ I got two phones. ♪
One for my friends, one for my drone.
(laughs)
(upbeat music)
We've got all four of our drones lined up.
We're gonna do a quick little test.
Basically just getting a
nice little camera view here
without anything moving.
I do have to shoot the Spark separately,
because it connects to Wi-Fi
and all of these things
are interfering with it.
So first we'll shoot these
three, then the Spark.
Hopefully, it'll sort of look the same.
Record.
Phantom record.
Every 4K 30,
4K 30.
I'm gonna do a quick
little walk in front of it.
(upbeat music)
Hello.
- Is that what you want?
- [Man] Yeah.
Alright.
(upbeat music)
(moves into dance music)
(blades spinning)
- So we've got the Mavic
Pro Platinum out right now,
and one of the things
that was new about this
is it supposedly is 40% quieter.
And listening to it now,
(blades spinning)
(birds squawking)
It is a lot more quiet
even than the Mavic Air.
(upbeat music)
So after reviewing the footage
from all four of the drones,
one of the things that I
was the most shocked at
was the variance in
color between the four.
I put everything on auto.
Auto color balance, auto exposure,
pretty much everything
so that you guys can see
exactly what you would be getting
directly out of the drones.
One of the things that I thought though,
was kind of shocking,
is the best auto color
came from the Spark.
I've even noticed differences
between the two of the same exact drones,
like my sister, we both have a Mavic Pro,
and even flying those on
seemingly the same settings,
sometimes I will be like,
"This looks different than yours."
I feel like that's something
that's pretty common,
but what's great is you can
pretty much customize anything.
So depending upon what the light is like,
so you can set the color balance
to match wherever you are.
Another cool thing that
we tried out in Malibu
is, Nathan was flying his Phantom 4,
and he added a lot onto his footage.
So he was doing this in
camera, on the drone,
so basically what I'm gonna show you now
is what he shot.
This is right from the drone to your eyes.
I am doing no color corrections.
All happened within spec.
(gentle electronic music)
- My personal philosophy on
shutter speed for drones,
is that you should actually shoot
with a slower shutter speed.
So, if you're filming
at 30 frames a second,
it's not a bad idea to
film at a 30th of a second.
So you have to have mutual density filter.
When the drone is moving through space,
you're taking pictures as you shoot video.
So it feels steppy.
As you watch playback of a drone,
with a sharp shutter that's moving fast.
It feels like
ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba.
So I started the day with my ND filter.
This is the DJI, and
this is the eight filter.
- So far there aren't any
available yet for the Mavic Air,
but I do use them
when I'm flying with
my Mavic or my Phantom.
Especially on sunny days because
it makes a huge difference.
One of the things that I forgot to mention
on the Mavic Air review,
is they have two new
smart capture features.
They have an astroid and boomerang.
So basically the drone will
do a set flight pattern
and they'll save that right to your phone,
so you're able to share
that out immediately.
So I'd say that my favorite
is probably the astroid.
So basically the drone follows
a flight pattern directly up.
So it does a really cool spherical shot
of everything around you.
(upbeat music)
Also boomerang, it just takes off
and creates a boomerang pattern.
So it goes up, out, and then back directly
where it started.
(upbeat music)
So far I am loving the Mavic Air,
it's amazing but the only
problem is the battery life.
It does only last 21 minutes
which is still a fair
amount of flight time
but I am so used to having extra batteries
and for this I only had one,
so I've been struggling
in shooting this video
for the past like week and a half,
because every time I go to film,
I only have like 21
minutes until I can go back
and charge the battery.
Right now, the sun is going down,
my battery is dead so,
whatever I shot is whatever I shot.
The batteries die very, very quickly.
So I definitely recommend if you are going
to be getting this, do
get the fly more package.
It is worth the extra money
for the extra batteries
'cause you're gonna need 'em.
Hey, Jen,
do you think that I could have that,
that time lapse you're shooting?
I'll buy you dinner, I'll buy you dinner!
- Oh my goodness.
- Guys this time lapse, is courtesy
of "It's Me, Jenna E" YouTube channel.
Go subscribe.
- Hey,
- Ah,
- Did you let me see the new drone
or fly the new drone, at all?
- Not yet.
I'm sorry.
- This is gonna cost you.
- Dinner.
- This is, this is,
It's Me, Jenna E, hard work.
I pressed a button.
(upbeat music)